e buongiorno allora capiamo come
funziona questo cosa ok
quindi è un buongiorno e near feature
design questa parola strana questa frase
strana il
progetto del futuro prossimo
cosa vorrà mai dire
per cercare di capire cosa potrebbe
voler dire near field design
immaginiamoci una scena
immaginiamo di essere a san bernardino
in california
concentriamoci
concentrati
all'ufficio della chevron la sede della
chevron che è un'azienda con cui
collaboriamo
in cui sono molto preoccupati c'è una
riunione sono molto preoccupati
perché potrebbero essere preoccupati
alla chevron una è una azienda globale
che fa energia che estrae petrolio che
distribuisce petrolio perché sono
preoccupati alla chevron in questa
riunione perché alla scena non si sono
accorti di una cosa veramente pericolosa
che non riescono più a capire i
quali sono i loro competitor quali sono
diciamo le persone le aziende le entità
che definiscono cosa è oggi e cosa sarà
in futuro nel prossimo futuro
una azienda che fa energia
sono raggiunti sono arrivati in questo
processo ha una strana conclusione sono
arrivati alla conclusione che il loro
maggior competitor
quindi il loro maggior concorrente di
mercato attualmente non è la shell o la
british petrolium o
che ne so petrobras occhi o chiunque
altro i maggior loro concorrente e
google
perché dovrebbe essere google il maggior
competitor di chevron un'azienda che
estrae e distribuisce petrolio perché
google con la sua attività e con il
fatto di essere il tramite della
conoscenza
di tante e tante persone tutto il mondo
ha radicalmente trasformato la
percezione di milioni e milioni e
milioni di persone
la percezione di cosa può essere una
azienda di che tratta di energia che
opera sul mercato energetico da
un'azienda che si occupa della
estrazione in qualche modo di energia e
distribuzione di energia a un'azienda
che gestisce informazioni per persone
che se la perché l'energia se la
producono da soli è un cambio
incredibile
e come possono come può un'azienda come
chevron e gigante enorme essersi trovata
in una condizione così particolare
perché in realtà
e futuro non esiste
il futuro non esiste il futuro è una
performance è una performance che accade
in
tanti modi diversi in generale accade
ogni giorno ogni minuto con ogni nostra
decisione con ogni volta che prendiamo
ad ogni bivio della nostra vita quindi
il futuro non esiste ed è una
performance
diciamo che che riguarda ogni istante
della nostra vita quindi
quindi è da qui che deriva il concetto
di yin e alfio cioè ok quindi capire
cosa è come sta per diventare il futuro
e per farlo possiamo partire da una da
un concetto la futurologia la patologia
è un una serie di discipline di pratiche
più o meno formalizzate che ha un
postulato di base che non esiste un
futuro singolo
esistono infiniti futuri questo bel
simbolo di infinito
che sono alternativi quindi possono o
meno accadere e sono a
verosimiglianza variabile quindi sono
più o meno probabili
questo è un concetto molto interessante
perché diciamo ce l'abbiamo a tutti noi
come come esperienza quindi del fatto
che in qualche modo possiamo e lo
facciamo partecipare alla creazione del
futuro ed è molto interessante
cosa si fa con questa nozione del del
futuro
degli infiniti possibili futuri a
probabilità
variabile
si può immaginare quindi che con tutte
le cose che facciamo con le decisioni
che prendiamo come decida di dicevamo
con leo degli oggetti che compriamo
realizziamo un enorme conversazione
quindi per conversazioni effettive
oppure per conversazioni
attuali quindi attuali quindi per le
cose che facciamo
realizza un enorme conversazione e il
futuro in qualche modo
emergere 9 da da questa enorme
conversazione ok
che per cosa è importante diciamo poter
capire per come emerge il futuro è
importante per due motivi con
l'accelerazione del
della tecnologia e della mutazione
sociale ci ritroviamo sempre di più uno
stato di quella si chiama continuo sti
strops rottura continua evoluzione
radicale continua quindi mutamento
continuo del delle situazioni politiche
sociali economiche
tecnologiche
di ecosistema ambientale
e quindi ci può aiutare per avere
imparare ad avere a che fare con questo
stato di rottura di disruption continua
e poi oltretutto questo stato di
disruption continua questo stato di
rottura continua e anche molto
particolare perché avviene per emergenze
per emergenze successive ok ok quindi
quelle che qui ho
evidenziato come cambiamenti e mutazioni
temporanei e
nomadici ok e quindi come si fa ad avere
a che fare con l'emergenza continua
tutto questo per tutto questo per tutte
questo genere di
di di esigenze è veramente importante
sapere avere a che fare con diciamo il
futuro prossimo
e quindi che cos'è il futuro prossimo
quindi come si descrive il futuro
prossimo il futuro prossimo si descrive
in termini di come cambia il linguaggio
di come cambiano e quindi come cambia
gli immaginari se usiamo la versione se
adottiamo la nella versione del
linguaggio che lo definisce come il modo
in cui creiamo il mondo se ci pensate
creiamo il mondo parlandone no in in
tanti modi questo il
capire il futuro prossimo ha molto a che
vedere
diciamo con il fatto di poter capire
come si trasforma nel linguaggio e
quindi di capire come si trasformano
commessi da sono gli immaginari delle
persone è tutto nell'ottica di non solo
di avere il senso del di ciò che è
possibile per esempio tecnologicamente
ma di avere il senso di che cosa è
preferibile e desiderabile quindi la
domanda importante non è solo che cosa è
possibile per esempio danni delle
tecnologie ma soprattutto che cosa è
desiderabile no che cosa è preferibile
che cosa da tanti punti di vista e
quindi per farlo dobbiamo avere a che
fare con gli esseri umani gli esseri
umani che vivono le loro vite di tutti i
giorni
gli esseri umani che a un certo punto si
trovano ad avere dei comportamenti
ricorrenti quindi dei dei pattern
ricorrenti noi questi batteri chiamiamo
rituali non a caso se questo libro molto
bello di nicolas nova che è un'altra
persona molto in gamba che si occupa di
nihal sul design che si chiama curious
rituals che si occupa questo libro di
descrivere questi
questi cure ostruito e spirituali e
curiosi ed emergenti che sono emersi
quindi nella società che sono apparsi
nella società grazie oa causa di dei
telefoni cellulari per esempio per
esempio uno di questi curious di hitwise
lo chiama il sottomarino una volta
quando le persone andavano al ai
concerti
andavano i concetti sono così
e ora quando le persone vanno ai
concerti fanno così
ok oppure fanno così si fanno la foto
con con il cellulare
questo è un cui due street once questo è
un sottomarino e
alcuni anni fa a pochi anni fa l'altro
mese erano cose strane invece adesso ci
sono interi servizi dedicati al
sottomarino a quello che una volta era
un furious ritual
quindi è di fondamentale importanza
riuscire a mappare questi questi rituali
emergenti queste nuove cose di cui non
abbiamo una spiegazione
mi farò un esempio
che tra l'altro è un esempio che con
tutta la sua improbabilità abbiamo
abbiamo presentato al office for science
and technologies della casa bianca
in questo esempio abbiamo creato
un'azienda fasulla
abbiamo creato un'azienda fasulla il cui
modello di business è molto particolare
questa azienda fasulla raccoglie sui
siti pornografici
webcam incontri eccetera eccetera
raccoglie i messaggi pubblici in cui le
persone oltre a lasciare il messaggio
porcello
sexy o quant'altro ha lasciato anche il
loro numero di telefono quindi messaggi
pubblici in cui ci sono dei commenti
tipo ei debiti puoi divertire chiamami
il mio numero è 347 bla bla bla
esce fuori questo è un curioso ritual
perché tantissime persone in barba alla
privacy in barba a qualsiasi
considerazione tantissime persone sui
social network lasciano il loro numero
di sui social network in particolare
quelli pornografici
lasciano il loro numero di telefono nei
commenti
e che cosa abbiamo fatto quindi abbiamo
fatto questa azienda
questo era lo slogan dell'azienda ok
quindi logan visualizzato dell'azienda
che prende tutte questi numeri di
telefono li mette su dei quadri e vende
questi quadri quindi tu puoi acquistare
un quadro
per 50 dollari in cui ecco che arriva un
quadro con una grafica generativa con un
commento porcello e con un numero di
telefono che può chiamare
è incredibile perché in realtà questo
che cos'era questo è un progetto di
ricerca ma che abbiamo attuato in in
questo modo particolare è un progetto
ricerca che ha avuto molta risonanza è
stato è stato ripreso su si nn è stato
ripreso sua in b si è stato ripreso
insomma non mi faccio l'elenco insomma
tanti giornali da tanti media è stato un
mese facebook insomma è stata è successo
un casino è stato il post con più
commenti sul blog sa che al blog di
wight combinato insomma un macello così
e quindi che cosa ci ha permesso di fare
ci ha permesso di
registrate cosa stava avvenendo
cosa sta avvenendo come le persone
percepivano questa possibilità questo
possibile futuro quindi dicevamo come si
fa a fare l'ingresso il design si deve
imparare ad avere a che fare con gli
esseri umani
questo è un era all'epoca un esempio di
nerf il design
non so quanti di voi se lo ricordano
questo era un oggetto che ha cambiato
completamente lo scenario è stata una
disruption incredibile ed emerge dal
fatto che alcuni designer hanno notato
che le persone vede in mente il ghetto
box quelle radio gigantesche che le
persone si portavano appresso
le persone che portavano appresso il
ghetto box e quindi è stato inventato
questo oggetto come
prima opportunità di personalizzare i lo
spazio
personale in modo in modo audio ok
questo anche a molto in questo oggetto
anche ha molto in comune con il
precedente ok perché con considerazioni
simili
l'iphone è importante perché è vuoto ok
perché lo spazio per l'espressione
personale pro è vuoto e pronto per
essere riempito di applicazioni quindi è
uno spazio di espressione nello spazio
di performance
quindi cosa fa cosa fa un erpice
designer fa questa cosa qua fa questa
mappa qua
con la quale vi lascerò
gli fece designer quindi osserva forse
un po ve la leggo forse un po piccola
osserva quelle che sono le realtà quella
che è la realtà consensuale quindi
quella che ti scriviamo noi come
come realtà ok come come la realtà che
ci circonda come che riconosciamo come
la realtà che ci circonda
osserva quello che si definisce lo
strange now quindi adesso strano ok
quindi tutto l'insieme di tutte quelle
cose che
riconosciamo come ricorrenti cose che
accadono ma che non sono ancora
codificate che a cui non abbiamo
attribuito
ancora un significato codificato e
quindi è una pratica etnografico che è
quindi la dic il riconoscimento dello
stress now e
unisce l'analisi dello strange now
all'analisi delle felici e possibili
this quindi l'analisi dello stato delle
arti delle tecnologie per fare cosa per
per fare questa cosa qua che si chiama
il pallino rosso che si chiama il design
for the new normal
quindi qual è lo scopo di questa di
tutta questa cosa è questa cosa qua
questo è un
come si fa il miglior fitch e design
si unisce l'analisi dello stato delle
arti delle tecnologie lì è stata una
cosa una slide quindi stato di arten
technologies
quindi lo stesso studio di che cosa si
può fare tecnologicamente e
tecnicamente con lo studio dei dei
rituali emergenti per creare delle mappe
di futuro del futuro da cui vengono
delle idee e che si attuano per attivare
dei simulacri ok degli stati di
sospensione del reale
della realtà in cui si può costruire un
mondo si può costruire un mondo in forma
transmediale ok si può consigliare un
mondo immersivo pensate ad esempio di
inconscio sporn quindi si può creare per
esempio un'azienda fa sulla finta con in
questo caso si possono fare anche cose
normali e questo questo mondo questo
mondo immersivo
diventa l'opportunità per far sì che le
persone si esprimano no quindi si
esprimano su che cosa desiderano su che
cosa vogliono su che cosa
su come reagiscono su cosa vedono come
loro futuro preferibile o desiderabile
ok e quindi questa è la
è la metodologia che vi volevo di cui
volevo parlare oggi
quindi il futuro diventa una performance
questi erano veramente gli scorre
rapidamente sono dei lavori di design
che abbiamo fatto con degli studenti
quindi una pillola ma per registrare i
propri pensieri una un sistema ed un
sistema sanitario
totalmente basato sul quanti fight self
quindi cosa succederebbe se per esempio
la finlandia
utilizzasse un sistema
di produzione di produzione diciamo di
assistenza sanitaria
collegato totalmente a dei sensori
biometrici per esempio nell'ipotesi che
facevamo il costo del sistema sanitario
nazionale
diminuirebbe del 70 per cento e quindi
questa è una medicina oppure questi
scenari per esempio abbiamo fatto uno
scenario con degli altri studenti in cui
si produceva si produceva anelano
tecnologicamente del del cibo e delle
delle cose che possono essere anche
organiche e tramite delle stampanti 3d
nano tecnologiche tutte questo per che
per dire che il futuro quindi non esiste
e possiamo con queste metodologie e con
altre metodologie
trasformarlo in una performance che di
cui diamo attuazione con le nostre
decisioni tutti i giorni grazie